and don't answer this question if you
don't want your matter but i have
i don't know why you brought this up but
i did hear you discuss you had an
extraordinary disagreement
uh with your wife about yourself
do you know what i'm talking about by
myself you mean yes yeah
ooh
listen you know this story do not listen
with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff
and i just have no interest and of
course being circumcised i said
they were chatting they're married
they're married they're allowed
and she said she said
you're not circumcised i said
what do you mean you've only known me a
few all my life i remember my mother
telling me why because it was
fashionable at the time
she said you're not circumcised i said
that's ridiculous
i should know if i'm circumcised of
course i am
end of conversation but the next day i
happen to be seeing my doctor
are you okay
i was seeing my doctor for my annual
physical of course so
uh while he was down there
i said excuse me oh by the way uh
erv um my wife and i a little
disagreement um
i i am circumcised aren't i because
she says i'm not and he goes
nah
he said no no no it's not possible so he
looked down again and he said hey
i'm jewish i know the difference
i have grandchildren
you're gonna have to change your
facebook status
no more beef stew
well there's more beef stew
were you born in hawaii i wasn't born in
hawaii i always lived there in san
francisco but i
did a lot of my growing up there so yeah
so it was amazing i don't know
i don't think me
what's more you say for years i've
always said well when we were there you
gave me a big speech like this is my
land i started
like spiritual speech about how it all
started
[Laughter]
hawaii was beautiful beautiful uh
you know mountainside and lushness and
and uh we shot in this beautiful place
called kuala ranch where uh
jurassic park the original jurassic park
was shot and the ones uh after that as
well
and it was just amazing but you didn't
like it he hated it no no this is the
problem
i didn't i didn't like it at all i mean
outside of the the spiritual grounds
that you took me to and i swear you even
sung a song
you were like i don't have to share that
with you
we'll talk about it later
so did you bring your medals with you no
we did oh i thought you might be wearing
them oh no they're just casually in the
back pockets
these are proper olympic medals
wow they're marion have you seen an
olympic medal
i actually did
is there anyone in ireland who hasn't
seen those medals
they look like me around the
[Laughter]
and of course now michael down in
killarney word must have reached you of
the o'donovan oh for sure i mean i
wasn't in killarney at the time but uh
everybody knew about it that's for sure
yeah yeah and
marion watching that clip and could you
understand the accents
nothing not a word i understood
since
just that once the movie says with
michael would just take carey accent
[Applause]
so listen cause the people
people love the interviews you did
during the olympics but like you guys
knew you were being funny while you were
doing the interviews
i don't know i think it was funny
because they were being themselves
yeah well to be fair we weren't trying
to be serious like but yeah
and just yeah you just kind of happened
you did seem very happy to be in rio i
was quite serious about the whole
situation
every time we told there's a chute like
yeah
and you have to understand like people
ask us these questions all the time
after races it just so happened to put a
camera in front of us in rio
i don't know you won a silver medal so
suddenly everyone was interested
but this is but the great thing is this
is like ireland has never won
any medal in rowing before have they
well not at the olympics no but they
have a few world championship titles all
right but it's
the first olympic medal yeah
and the interview where you talked about
your approach to the race
the phrases you used in that so explain
to the people what you what you said in
that
do you know what about going to be fast
you can yeah
yeah yeah it's just a fairly simple
sport like
[Laughter]
this is based on your life i mean this
is things yeah
i mean loosely graham
no but things like isn't the washing
machine that happened to you
what the the washing you were very
hungover
oh yeah
great tell tony foster that story
all their stories are really cool though
grail
when i was teaching this is what this
show is based on
i went home one weekend and i was in my
30s i was probably 33 years of age i
went home to see my
mother and then i went back and while i
was at home my mother did my washing for
me because i was only 33.
then i went back on the on the sunday
night
i got really drunk and then i
went for a curry and then the next day i
went into school
i'm going to i went into school and it
was a school in slow and it was
quite a rough school but they had a
really brilliant hearing impaired
department so there were
hearing impaired kids who uh you know
struggled
they were they were really looked after
in school anyway i was really hungover i
went there and about break time i felt
really uncomfortable i thought
something's not right you know
so i went to the toilet and i pulled my
trousers down
and some of my mother's knickers had got
got mixed up in the washington
and i was wearing my mother's underwear
and i went oh god no oh i remember going
are you loser this is
such a low point you [ __ ] loser
and then the curry and the boot the
curry and the booze kicked in from the
night before
so i i i did like a fecal jackson
pollock
and i started i started going oh god not
this
not this as well oh jesus so i cleaned
myself up and i pulled my mother's pants
back
and i went back into the um classroom
and i saw one of the hearing impaired
kids just looking at me like this
and that's when i remembered that my i
had a microphone directly
a lot of young actors they you know they
revere you so they look to you
the other thing you inspire is
impressions people doing impressions now
when people do impressions of you is it
like
sort of nails on a chalkboard or do you
kind of enjoy it
no i kind of enjoy it especially if they
do it well
uh so no i i it's great
i love it i only ask
no because because any hiddlestoners
watching will know
uh tom hiddleston does impressions you
do with a lot of people so who's in your
canon
it's a it's a expression of admiration
just to be clear
um so i do i do uh impressions of people
that i
i admire and i sort of listen to them i
get the first time i did an impression
um that anyone was aware of i was just
telling a story about midnight in paris
the woody allen film i was in
and how i never read the whole script
and i and i thought it was set in the
20s
and um i turned up and i bumped into
owen wilson who didn't look like he was
in the 20s at all uh
and uh and i said to him i said so wait
hang on who are you playing because i'm
playing f scott fitzgerald and i know
corey stoles playing ernest hemingway
and we're all playing figures of history
and he went
oh no no no no no i'm from now i go back
into
there's a time machine it's kind of cool
and it's kind of woody and you just kind
of it's kind of awesome
very good but uh
i've done it i mean
[Applause]
impressions of my fellow avengers um uh
i think everyone does an impression of
christopher walken because he's just
he's such an easy
kind of you know i feel
like what this show needs is more
cowbell
depends on what
you'd like me to say basically
there's no punctuation
anything that comes out of my mouth
i know whole pages of heat you surprised
me
so i there's this there's the scene in
the middle of the film which you'll be
familiar with you were there
the one person you don't need
they're separated like a great thriller
they're separated
from for the entire film and they meet
twice once at the end once in the middle
and it takes place at a restaurant la
it's a great scene it's one of the great
pieces of screen acting you can hope to
watch there it is
there's a picture of it it's like a it's
a mutual recognition
of each other anyway so there's a bit
where they have like they sit and have
coffee and i have tea and talk about
stuff i'm going on i apologize
anyway so al pacino at one point al
pacino says this he goes uh
so
[Laughter]
we're sitting here like a couple of
regular fellas i mean
you do what you do i do what i got to do
if i'm there and i gotta put you away
i won't like it but if it's between you
and some poor bastard whose wife you're
gonna turn into a widow
brother you are going down
[Music]
and then and then and so then and then
it cut and then michael mann cuts back
to the esteemed gentleman at the end of
the sofa
what if you do got me boxton
i'm not gonna put you down
moving face to face yeah
but i will not hesitate not for a second
[Applause]
i feel like i've gone into a parallel
universe where um
you're playing all these players i
apologize that's great
you're the president of ken brown that
was my favorite scene was it your
favorite thing yeah
is it still yeah
no no but my favorite scene that was
written before not because of
or doing it but i just my favorite scene
written in the film
you know that it's a great piece of
writing yeah it feels like it plays in
two
in two singles in a way like yeah yeah
and it's it's like
the most beautiful game of tennis did
you each do lots of takes what did you
do lots of things forget how many takes
we did i don't think we did more than
five to eight or nine at the moment
maybe maybe last second
you talk about your dreams and you talk
about your life
it's so great it's so great there's a
bit another bit where you go
we know you say he says he says uh
pacino says
so you never wanted a regular-type life
and and uh bob may i call you bob yeah
bob says what's that barbecues and ball
games
[Applause]
your mother loves you because you're her
daughter yeah but
she is actually a sort of a fan as well
you know it's not she's not quite that
it's
um she is oh goodness right
so my uh uh one day my mom came to set
on the star wars set uh and i was
getting this thing called cyber scanned
which is where you stand in this kind of
loads of cameras
and they kind of take your form and put
you into a computer and make a toy or a
some sort of merchandise or your face on
a cushion
um and so i go off and do this and i
come back and mom's like i've made a
great
friend and i'm like brilliant it's
lovely excellent and
she's like the merchandise you know
director of all of star wars or
something and i'm like wow
very impressive and then before i know
it what comes in the post
um is loads of cushions
my face on it so my own mum i guess
she gets to see it a fair amount you
know but apparently it's not enough so
i was kind of blown away how much
merchandise there
is yes and it's not i mean it's just the
beginning it was like the
pre-merchandise not even the real stuff
is out yet
and my mom has all of it and doesn't
know about the doll yet so well
this is so weird i don't know is this in
your flat or her house
goodness right okay so basically she'll
be really funny if i came home and it
was everywhere in my room
okay so this is this is this is emilia's
actual bedroom
[Applause]
we found the photo but it's not like
that now there is another reason why i'm
saying
the first date back to that yeah
come on in
[Laughter]
this little thing once i don't have a cv
i just have a bedroom
but this is cool though so your mother a
big fan
but brad pitt also a perfect fan that
was the best night of my life
yes
tell the story quickly
[Applause]
sheets slippers uh no yeah there was
this auction
thing that happened and um i they called
me and said would you you know do you
want to do you want to um
auction something off like maybe sort of
an experience
watching the show with you or something
and i was like okay it's lovely it's
great for charity yeah it'll be for some
you know
some something yeah and it'll be fine
anyway so i'll get there and it's
amazing
it'll be a good thing um i get there and
it's basically like this it's basically
it's the oscars there's so many
celebrities in this room and i suddenly
remember that i said that i would
auction something off
and so the fear grows so i was petrified
absolute petrified and then um
the the person whose table i was on is a
friend and he was being very kind and
kind of put the paddle up and i was like
thanks very much
that's very sweet that'll be that uh and
then someone else's paddle up went up
across the other side of the room
and i didn't really know and then
suddenly it was sort of becoming a bit
of money and i was kind of thinking oh
this is
absolutely mental and someone went it's
brad pitt and i was like oh
sure yeah exactly and i look over to the
room and he's
got his paddle up brad's paddle that's
brown
well it didn't work out because the
person whose friend was my friend i
think was probably all set up
personally who was my friend ended up
you know doing the highest bid
but
but yeah i just kind of looked over with
just the most insane emoji heart eyes
being like this is just the greatest
moment of my life
you